Le processus d'urbanisation a commencé à la fin des années 1700
et n’a cessé d'augmenter depuis.
On estime que d'ici 2050,
66 % de la population vivra dans des villes,
et les Nations Unies, l'Organisation Mondiale de Santé
et le Forum Économique Mondial nous avertissent
que si on ne prévoit pas l'accroissement de densité,
certains problèmes urbains actuels, comme l'inégalité, le trafic et le crime
ne pourraient qu'empirer.
Donc, les urbanistes et les promoteurs immobiliers
mettent beaucoup d'effort et de créativité
dans la conception de nos prochaines villes plus denses et larges.
Je pense différemment.
L'urbanisation atteint, en fait, la fin du cycle
et les gens commenceront désormais à retourner à la campagne.
Vous pensez probablement à la tendance.
Alors, je vous dirai quelque chose :
les tendances socio-économiques ne perdurent pas.
Vous savez, il y a 12 000 ans,
tout le monde était parfaitement heureux,
errant sur la terre, chassant et cueillant.
Et ensuite, la tendance change,
et la nouveauté est d'habiter dans une ferme et posséder du bétail,
jusqu'à un nouveau changement.
On arrive alors à la révolution industrielle.
En fait, cela a démarré le processus d'urbanisation.
Et qu'est-ce qui l'a déclenché ?
La vapeur, les machines,
les nouveaux processus chimiques...
en deux mots, l'innovation technologique.
Et je crois que la technologie peut également finir ce cycle.
J'ai passé ma carrière à travailler sur l'innovation.
J’aime ça, j'aime mon emploi.
Je peux travailler avec des drones,
des imprimantes 3D et des lunettes intelligentes,
et pas juste celles qu'on achète dans les magasins, mais aussi les prototypes.
C'est très amusant parfois.
Certaines de ces technologies
offrent de nouvelles possibilités qui changeront radicalement
notre façon d'agir.
Et dans quelques années,
on profitera des avantages de la vie urbaine
n'importe où.
Réfléchissez à ça.
Si on pouvait vivre dans un endroit avec un faible taux de criminalité,
plus d'espace,
un coût de vie plus faible,
et moins de trafic ;
certes, beaucoup de personnes voudraient ça,
mais elles pensent qu'elles n'ont pas le choix.
Vous devez vivre en ville.
Cependant, dans le passé, les gens ont déménagé vers les villes
non pas parce qu'ils aimaient la vie urbaine,
mais pour les choses qu'ils pourraient y posséder :
plus de possibilités d'emploi,
un accès aisé aux services et aux biens
et une vie sociale riche.
Alors, approfondissons.
Plus de possibilités d'emploi.
Est-ce encore vrai ?
Les gens du bureau commencent à réaliser
que travailler et être au bureau
n'est plus la même chose.
Selon une étude de Global Workplace Analytics,
plus de 80% des effectifs américains aimeraient travailler à domicile.
Et savez-vous combien une entreprise dépense pour avoir un bureau ?
11 000 dollars par employé et par an.
Si seulement la moitié de ces travailleurs
télétravaillaient même 50% du temps,
les économies aux États-Unis dépasseraient 500 milliards de dollars,
et cela baisserait les gaz à effet de serre de 54 millions de tonnes.
C'est l'équivalent
de 10 millions de voitures en moins par an.
Mais, malgré la préférence de télétravailler pour la plupart des gens,
la technologie actuelle rend l'expérience isolante.
Ce n'est pas confortable.
Ça ne donne pas l'impression d'être présent.
Mais cela va changer
avec la convergence de deux technologies :
la réalité augmentée et les robots de téléprésence.
La réalité augmentée, désormais,
nous permet d'emporter notre bureau partout.
On requiert : un ordinateur portable, une paire de lunettes intelligentes
et on peut désormais emporter nos emails et nos tableurs
partout où on va.
Les conférences vidéos et les appels vidéos sont si communs de nos jours,
mais ils doivent encore s'améliorer.
C'est-à-dire, tous ces petits visages sur un écran plat,
on ne sait même pas qui parle parfois.
Aujourd'hui, on a une meilleure option que les appels vidéos statiques :
un robot de téléprésence moyen...
Je l'appelle « tablette sur un bâton ».
(Rires)
On peut se déplacer
et contrôler ce qu'on regarde.
C'est mieux, mais loin d'être parfait.
Savez-vous que la plupart de la communication humaine est non-verbale ?
Bien, le robot ne vous donne rien de tout ça.
Il ressemble à un extra-terrestre.
Mais avec le progrès de la réalité augmentée,
on mettra facilement le robot dans un hologramme
qui ressemble à une personne bouge comme elle.
Ça arrivera.
Ou bien, oubliez le robot.
Nous entrons dans la réalité virtuelle
où tout le monde se rencontre dans le cyber-espace.
Dans quelques années, cela paraîtra si réel
qu'on ne verra pas la différence.
Parlons maintenant de la raison suivante :
l'accès aux services et aux biens.
Désormais, on peut faire tout ça en ligne.
Selon une étude réalisée par comScore,
aux US, l'an dernier, les acheteurs ont fait
plus de la moitié de tous leurs achats en ligne
et le marché mondial de l'e-commerce
est estimé à deux mille milliards de dollars.
Et il est prévu d'atteindre 2,38 mille milliards à la fin de 2017,
d'après eMarketer.
D'un point de vue logistique,
la densité bénéficie aux livraisons.
Fournir des biens à un centre commercial est facile.
On peut expédier de grosses quantités aux magasins
et les clients ramèneront leurs achats chez eux.
L'e-commerce implique faire des envois
et les livrer à domicile.
C'est plus cher.
C'est la différence entre avoir une fête d'anniversaire pour 20 personnes,
et apporter un morceau de gâteau
à chacun de vos 20 amis chez eux.
Heureusement, ils vivent proches l'un de l'autre en ville.
La densité aide.
Parlons de livraisons de l'e-commerce à la campagne...
celles-ci prennent des siècles.
Le camion doit parfois parcourir des kilomètres entre un foyer et le suivant.
Ces livraisons sont les plus chères.
Cependant, on a déjà résolu ce problème :
les drones.
Un véhicule avec un escadron de drones.
Le chauffeur fait quelques livraisons
et les drones en livrent d'autres tandis que le camion continue.
Ainsi, le coût de livraison est réduit...
et voilà :
de l'e-commerce économiquement abordable à la campagne.
Vous verrez :
les nouveaux foyers de nos télétravailleurs
pourraient avoir une nacelle pour drone dans le jardin.
Quand la livraison du dernier kilomètre sera résolue,
faire ses achats en ville ne sera plus nécessaire.
C'est la deuxième raison.
Voyons maintenant la raison suivante :
une vie sociale riche.
Est-il nécessaire d'être en ville pour cela ?
Les gens aujourd'hui
se font des amis, chattent, cancanent et flirtent
dans le confort de leur canapé.
(Rires)
Tout en portant leur pyjama préféré.
Il y a plus de 2 milliards d'utilisateurs de réseaux sociaux actifs dans le monde.
D'une certaine manière, cela indique qu'on est relié,
peu importe où on est.
C'est bien, mais pas complètement.
Parfois, on a tout de même besoin d'un vrai contact humain.
Ironiquement, la ville, avec sa densité de population,
n'est pas toujours ce qu'il y a de mieux pour cela.
En fait, plus les groupes sociaux diminuent,
plus ils deviennent forts.
Une étude récente, réalisée au Royaume-Uni
par le Bureau de la Statistique Nationale,
a montré un niveau de satisfaction de vie supérieur
chez les habitants des régions rurales.
À mesure que les gens s'installent à la campagne,
ils achètent des produits locaux,
des produits frais, des denrées
et des services d'entretien.
Ainsi, les bricoleurs, les petits ateliers et les sociétés de service prospèrent.
Certains de ces travailleurs urbains,
remplacés par l'automatisation industrielle,
trouveront peut-être d'autres emplois,
et ils déménageront aussi.
Et quand les gens auront déménagé à la campagne, que se passera-t-il ?
Pensez à des maisons hors-réseau et
autonomes avec des panneaux solaires,
des éoliennes et des services de recyclage de déchets
qui produisent leur propre énergie pour alimenter la voiture familiale.
On a toujours considéré les villes comme étant écoénergétiques,
mais le repeuplement de la campagne peut être écologique aussi.
Maintenant, vous pensez probablement aux avantages de la vie rurale.
(Rires)
Moi-même, j’y ai succombé.
Il y a six ans, ma femme et moi, on a fait nos valises
on a vendu notre appartement en Espagne,
et pour le même prix, on a acheté une maison avec un jardin,
et des petits oiseaux qui chantent le matin.
(Rires)
C'est génial d'y habiter.
On vit dans un petit village, pas à la campagne.
Cela sera mon suivant objectif :
une ferme rénovée
ni trop loin d'une ville, ni trop proche.
Là, j'aurai un endroit idéal d'atterrissage pour les drones.
(Rires)
Néanmoins, c'est mon opinion.
La vôtre peut différer,
car on dirait que je tente de vous convaincre
de vivre à la campagne.
Pas du tout.
(Rires)
Je ne veux pas ça...
Je crois seulement que plus de gens veulent y habiter
quand ils réalisent que la campagne peut leur profiter de la même façon.
Si vous n'aimez pas la campagne,
j’ai une bonne nouvelle :
les villes ne disparaîtront pas.
Mais au fur et à mesure que les gens déménageront,
une densité inférieure aidera à rétablir l'équilibre.
Enfin, je crois que vous devez penser à quelque chose :
vivre en ville est-il toujours obligatoire ?
Et plus important encore :
est-ce ce que vous le voulez ?
Merci beaucoup !
(Applaudissements)